Вітаю усіх на занятті з української
мови! Мене звати Саша Шевченко
я викладачка школи “Майбутні” та
засновниця ЗНОшного клубу “Неон”.
Сьогодні ми почнемо повторювати певні
теми і візьмемо словосполучення і речення.
Для початку пригадаємо
що таке словосполучення.
Це синтаксична одиниця, яка
поєднує два або більше слів,
і обов'язково в цій сполуці має бути
головне слово і від нього залежне.
Дивіться: говорити (як?)
голосно, страва (яка?) cмачна,
квіти
(кого? на що?) на пам'ять.
Якщо ми розуміємо словосполучення так
просто, чому ж ми інколи так плутаємося?
А тому, що насправді ми не
знаємо, що не є словосполученням.
Подивімося:
Підмет і присудок ніколи
не є словосполученням,
тому що підмет і присудок - це речення.
Друге:
Іменник або займенник
разом з прийменником.
Нам потрібно пригадати. Іменники
і займенник, думаю, всі пам'ятаємо
це самостійні частини мови.
Іменник називає предмет, а
займенник вказує, але не називає.
А прийменник (в українській
мові все насправді просто,
із самих назв можна зрозуміти, що це
за слова), от прийменник стоїть ПРИ імені,
при іменних частинах
мови, а їх всього чотири:
іменник, прикметник,
займенник та числівник.
Відповідно такі сполуки ніколи
не будуть словосполученнями.
Подивіться: біля будинку,
під деревом і так далі.
Наш прийменник не є
самостійною частиною мови,
тому він не може
утворювати словосполучення.
Третє:
Однорідні члени речення.
Наприклад: він і вона, смачні і соковиті.
Зверніть увагу: пам'ятаєте, ми говорили,
що словосполучення має
мати головне слово і залежне,
а в однорідних немає цієї
залежності - обидва слова головні.
Відповідно, якщо залежності немає,
то це не може бути словосполученням.
Четверте:
Стійкі сполуки. Що таке стійкі сполуки?
Це в першу чергу фразеологізми
та різні власні назви.
Наприклад, Чорне море.
Подивімося: Чорне море - це його
назва, це не характеристика моря.
От якби я сказала: море бурхливе, море
спокійне, то це було б словосполучення,
а у випадку з власною назвою - ні.
Ахіллесова п'ята - це фразеологізм.
Ми тут не маємо на увазі, що
це п'ята, яка належить Ахіллесу,
ми вказуємо на фразеологізм,
що це слабке місце людини.
Відповідно, ця сполука
слів не є словосполученням.
Так само ловити гав - ми не маємо
на увазі, що ми ловимо пташок,
а маємо на увазі
байдикувати, нічого не робити.
Відповідно, ця сполука
слів, цей фразеологізм
так само не є словосполученням.
І останнє, п'яте:
Різні складені форми слів. Що
значить складені форми слів?
Це слова, за допомогою
яких ми робимо нові форми.
Наприклад, ступені порівняння - найбільш
смачний, більш-менш смачний і так далі,
майбутній час - буду танцювати, ти будеш
танцювати, він буде танцювати і так далі.
Ось ці будеш танцювати чи буду
танцювати не є словосполученням.
Так само форми наказового способу
для третьої особи однини і множини.
Наприклад, хай танцює, нехай танцюють
- оці сполуки не є словосполученням.
Спробуємо перевірити.
Потрібно обрати варіант,
у якому є словосполучення.
Подивімося: перший варіант - це
складена форма, наказовий спосіб.
Відповідно, це не є словосполученням.
Другий варіант - пекти раків - ми
маємо на увазі не конкретно пекти раків,
а фразеологізм, тобто червоніти.
Відповідно, це не є словосполученням.
І останнє що в нас залишилося?
Смачно готувати - готувати (як?) смачно
є залежність одного слова від іншого.
Відповідно, це словосполучення.
Йдемо далі.
Розібралися зі
словосполученням, тепер речення.
В першу чергу, ми маємо знати, що
речення - це основна синтаксична одиниця.
За допомогою речення ми
можемо з вами комунікувати.
Речення - це відносно повноцінна
частина, яка виражає нашу думку.
Наприклад:
Шерех. Шепіт диких трав. А хмари бігли.
Зверніть увагу, що речення може складатися
з одного слова, як у варіанті: Шерех
або двох - головне, щоб воно
мало смислове навантаження.
Також зверніть увагу, що речення
не просто має якийсь набір слів,
а речення поєднує слова між
граматично, а не тільки смислового.
Порівняйте: Колише пшеничний узбережжя я
стежина пам'ять жива - нічого не зрозуміло
купа якихось слів які ми окремо розуміємо,
але суцільної думки це речення не має.
Відповідно, реченням
воно називатися не може.
Порівняйте його з наступним:
Колише на пшеничнім узбережжі
мене стежина пам'яті жива
от уже і бачимо сенс цього
речення, бачимо, що слова змінилися,
узгодились між собою граматично.
Тобто, речення - це не тільки про смисл,
а ще і про узгодження слів між собою.
Потрібно також звернути
увагу, як я сказала вище,
що речення може
складатися з одного слова,
але інколи це просто слово.
Як же це відрізнити?
Подивіться:
пожежа і Пожежа!
Тобто, речення залежить від
ситуації його використання і від інтонації
від того сенсу, який
ми в нього вкладаємо.
Якщо я просто кажу слово “пожежа”, я
характеризую якесь явище горіння чогось.
Якщо ж я в ситуації, де відбувається
пожежа і вигукую: “Пожежа!”,
то ми тоді розуміємо, що
це вже самостійне речення,
просто вона складається з одного слова.
Як відрізнити речення
від словосполучення?
Смисл, інтонація,
граматична узгодженість - так.
Але основне, те, що відрізняє речення від
словосполучення - це граматична основа.
Граматична основа - це
наш з вами підмет і присудок.
Дуже часто граматичну основу
називають синтаксичним центром,
або ще дуже розумно -
семантичним центром.
Семантичний значить
смисловий, значеннєвий.
Крім підмета і присудка, головних
членів речення, цієї граматичної основи,
які утворюють речення, у нас є
ще й другорядні члени речення:
означення, обставина і додаток.
Речення можуть бути різних видів.
Є всього три характеристики, за якими
ми можемо виділити речення на різні види.
Перша характеристика - за
складом граматичної основи.
Пригадаймо, граматична
основа - це підмет і присудок.
Подивімося: якщо у нас є або лише підмет,
або лише присудок, це односкладне речення.
Наприклад: Весна. Так,
як і було з “Пожежею”.
Люблю тепло - немає тут підмета
(хто любить?), але є присудок люблю.
Відповідно, і перше, і
друге речення - односкладні,
в них відсутній один
член граматичної основи.
А двоскладні речення - це ті, у
яких наявний і підмет, і присудок.
Наприклад: Настала весна. (хто?
що?) Весна (що зробила?) настала.
Спробуймо!
Знайдіть двоскладне речення.
(Увага на екран)
Для того, щоб визначити чи це
односкладне, чи двоскладне речення,
ми маємо визначити граматичну
основу, тобто підмет і присудок.
Подивімося!
У нас є присудок збудовано
і нам може здатися,
що будинок - це підмет,
але підмет у нас завжди
відповідає на запитання (хто? що?).
А тепер запитаємо:
збудовано (кого? що?) будинок.
А якщо це не (хто? що?),
значить підметом він не може бути.
Ще один лайфхак як можна
пізнати чи це підмет, чи це не підмет
спробуйте його замінити на
займенник він, вона, воно або вони.
Дивіться: він збудовано -
нелогічно, значит це не підмет,
тому тут у нас наявний тільки
присудок, а отже це односкладне речення.
Дивимося Б:
Немає жодних проблем.
Немає (кого? чого?)
проблем - це не підмет.
Відповідно, у нас є тільки
присудок, слово немає.
При чому зверніть увагу, якщо
у вас речення зі словом немає,
це зазвичай речення
односкладне, безособове.
І останнє, скоріш за все це наш з вами
правильний варіант, але перевіряємо.
Забави були готові - забави
(хто? що?) дійсно підмет,
і (що вони робили?) були
готові, а значить це присудок.
Відповідно, тут у нас є і підмет, і
присудок, а значить це двоскладне речення.
Знайдемо двоскладне.
Тут уже складніше, більше варіантів.
А) Без охоти нема роботи.
Я вже вам говорила про те, що якщо у вас
слово немає (нема - його скорочена форма),
це завжди односкладне, безособове,
тому цей варіант нам не підходить.
Дивимося на Б.
За гроші не купиш ні
батька, ні матері, ні родини.
Ти не купиш - підмет
пропущений, є тільки присудок,
значить односкладне - не підходить.
В) Хто батька-матір
зневажає, той добра не знає.
Може здатися складним, але
насправді ви запитуєте (хто?)
оце хто і є цим підметом.
Хто зневажає - відповідно, це двоскладне
речення, наш правильний варіант,
але маємо переконатися,
що інші не підходять.
Г) Виховав дитину в добру годину.
Ти виховав або він виховав.
Розуміємо, що підмет відсутній.
Відповідно, це односкладне речення.
Д) Нема кращого друженька.
Можемо не читати далі,
бачимо слово нема - розуміємо,
що це односкладне речення, безособове.
Відповідно, воно нам не підходить.
Наступна характеристика для виду речення
- це наявність другорядних членів речення.
Відповідно, дивіться, дуже просто
- із самих слів, знову ж таки, зрозуміло,
що у нас немає ніяких другорядних
членів речення, тобто є тільки підмет,
або тільки присудок, або вони обоє є,
але ні означення, ні обставини,
ні додатка немає, відповідно,
це буде непоширене
речення, тобто воно маленьке.
А якщо ж у вас уже з'являється
якийсь другорядний член речення,
воно стає поширене навіть якщо хоча б один
малюсінький з'являється, воно поширене.
Весна. Я радію.
Бачите, у нас звичайне
односкладне речення.
Я радію - тут є і підмет, і
присудок, але немає другорядних.
А от уже Настала довгождана
весна - весна (яка?) довгождана.
Відповідно, з'являється означення,
і це у нас уже поширене речення.
Спробуємо знайти поширене речення в рядку.
А) Багато літ перевернулось.
Дивимося:
Звертайте увагу, що у
вас може бути і три слова,
і чотири, але це не значить,
що речення буде поширеним.
Багато літ перевернулось.
Багато літ - це наш складений підмет.
Ми не можемо його
розірвати, тому це цілий підмет.
Відповідно, є підмет і присудок,
значить це речення непоширене.
Дивимось далі.
Б) Летить сніг.
Підмет і присудок - непоширене.
В) Ліс уже зеленіє.
Ліс (що робить?) зеленіє,
зеленіє (коли?) або (як?) уже.
Відповідно, таке маленьке слово
робить це речення поширеними.
Г) Співайте. У нас є тільки
присудок. Відповідно, непоширене.
Д) Він накивав п'ятами.
Подивімося: тут є підмет він, а
накивав п'ятами - фразеологізм.
Відповідно, це простий присудок, а
значить у нас є тільки підмет і присудок,
тому це речення непоширене.
Наступна характеристика -
за кількістю граматичних основ.
Відповідно, якщо у вас є
тільки одна граматична основа
і байдуже, яка це граматична основа - чи
це односкладне, чи двоскладне речення,
там може бути наявне тільки підмет,
тільки присудок, або їхнє поєднання,
але якщо вона тільки одна,
то це у вас просте речення.
Якщо ж у вас з'являється дві і більше
граматичні основи, це речення стає складним
Порівняйте.
Настала довгождана весна. Весна (що
зробила?) настала - одна граматична основа
Наступне: Настала
довгождана весна, світить сонце.
Весна настала і сонце світить - дві
граматичні основи,
а отже це складне речення.
Спробуємо попрактикуватися.
Вам потрібно знайти просте речення.
А) Була прекрасна липнева ніч, повноводний
місяць простилав на траві срібну стежку.
Подивімося
у нас тут ніч була прекрасна -
це перша граматична основа,
і далі місяць простилав -
друга граматична основа.
Якщо у нас дві граматичні основи.
значить це складне речення. Шукаємо далі.
Б) Уже останній сніг розтанув,
забравши за собою чистоту землі
і оголивши чорні видолинки.
Подивіться.
Може так здаватися, що речення
довжелезне, а отже воно складне, але ні -
речення може бути простим,
але ускладнене чимось.
У цьому випадку речення ускладнене
дієприслівниковими зворотами однорідними
забравши, оголивши, а граматична
основа у нас одна - сніг розтане.
Відповідно, це речення просте.
Нам підходить, перевіряємо.
В) Защебетав соловейко - пішла луна гаєм.
Соловейко (що зробив?)
защебетав, а луна пішла гаєм.
Відповідно, тут дві граматичні
основи, а значить це складне речення.
Наступне - усі речення прості, окрім…
Звертайте увагу на
формулювання самого завдання,
щоб не шукати просте
речення, а шукати “окрім”.
Тобто ми маємо знайти складне
речення, а всі інші будуть простими.
А) Софія Київська - джерело
для пізнання історії нашої культури,
зокрема мистецтва Київської Русі.
Дивимося: Софія Київська є джерело
- підмет і присудок.
Подивімось далі: у нас немає
більше граматичної основи,
наше речення просто ускладнене
відокремленим додатком
зокрема мистецтва Київської Русі.
Наступне речення.
Б) Протягом довгого віку
писанки сформувався певний вид
орнаменту й колірної гами,
характерний для окремого району.
Шукаємо граматичну основу.
Вид (що зробив?) сформувався.
Відповідно:
тут у нас характерний для окремого
району - це просто відокремлене означення.
В) Як деталь святкового вбрання
українок рушники використовувались
важливих подій родинного
життя, наприклад, на весіллі,
коли змінювався життєвий статус жінки.
Шукаємо граматичні основи.
Рушники використовувалися
- перша граматична основа,
і друга - статус змінювався.
Відповідно, тут у нас дві граматичні
основи, а отже це складне речення.
І останнє.
Г) У східних Карпатах
побутують геометричні орнаменти,
намальовані тонкими
жовтими білими контурами.
Що у нас тут виходить?
Орнаменти (що роблять?) побутують,
і у нас намальовані тонкими
жовтими білими контурами
це всього лише відокремлене означення.
Це просте речення, тому наш
правильний варіант речення - В.
Тепер спробуємо попрактикуватися.
Нам потрібно визначити
односкладні та двоскладні речення.
Стрімкі весни щоразу
змінювалися на спекотне літо.
Шукаємо граматичну основу.
Весни (що робили?) змінювалися,
значить є підмет і присудок,
а отже це двоскладне речення
Друге:
Роздуми обірвав плач тримісячного братика.
Шукаємо знову граматичну основу.
Плач (що зробив?) обірвав.
Відповідно, є підмет і присудок,
а отже це двоскладне речення.
До школи аж ніяк не тягнуло.
Намагаємося знайти особу
- кого ж то там тягнуло?
Особа відсутня, тобто підмета
немає, а отже це односкладне речення.
Ліворуч хата давня, наче гріх,
шибками посміхаються леваді.
Що тут? Хата - підмет,
(що робить?) посміхається,
а відповідно це наша граматична основа.
Вона повна,  а отже це двоскладне речення.
Наступне:
Вечір горнеться до землі.
Вечір (що робить?) горнеться
- теж є підмет і присудок,
а значить це двоскладне речення.
Лунко гриміли громи, і
злі блискавиці змигували.
Громи (що робили?) гриміли,
блискавиці (що робили?) змигували
тут у нас дві граматичні основи,
але ці дві граматичні основи повні,
тобто тут у нас насправді складне речення,
яке складається з двох
простих двоскладних речень.
Наступне:
Надворі було так гарно...
Намагаємося знайти підмет і присудок.
(хто?) - немає підмета, є
тільки присудок було гарно.
Відповідно, це односкладне речення.
Ключі від важких металевих дверей
лежали в тому ж міні-багажнику.
(хто? що?) ключі (що робили?) лежали.
Відповідно, це двоскладне речення.
А тепер спробуємо
відредагувати словосполучення.
Сміятися над другом.
Треба завжди ставити логічне запитання
від головного - сміятися не (над ким?),
а сміятися (з кого?).
Сміятися над кимось - це
калька з російської мови,
тому правильно сказати сміятися з
друга, хоча краще не сміятися з друзів.
Оволодівати знання.
Ставимо знову логічне запитання:
оволодівати (ким? чим?) знаннями.
Навчатися музиці.
Дуже часта помилка, але насправді слово
вчитися має поєднуватися з іменником,
тобто навчатися (кого? чого?) музики.
Вибачте мене.
Звучить, ніби вибачте (кого?) мене,
але насправді вибачте (кому?) мені.
Запобігати нещасних випадків
Запобігати (кому? чому?)
нещасним випадкам.
Пропустити по хворобі.
Поставимо запитання від головного слова:
пропустити (через що?) через хворобу.
Дивиться, такі типові словосполучення
в поєднанні з різними прийменниками
є дуже частими помилками.
Для цього потрібно правильно
узгоджувати їх між собою
і ставити запитання від
головного до залежного.
А тепер я пропоную вам змагання.
Потрібно знайти з поданого
речення дев’ять словосполучень.
Я починаю, а ви зі мною.
Молоді господарі - раз,
господарі землі - два,
по-материнськи зростила - три,
нас зростила - чотири,
піднесла до сонця - п’ять,
піднесла на крилі - шість,
жар любові - сім, в серце заронила - вісім
і жар заронила - дев’ять.
Я сподіваюся, що хтось з вас зробив
швидше, ніж я. А тепер перевіримо.
Дійсно, це всі наші дев’ять
словосполучень. Як ми мали їх відшукати?
В першу чергу, пам'ятаємо, що ми маємо
шукати від головного до залежного слова.
Подивімося на дев'ять словосполучень:
молоді господарі - господарі (які?) молоді
господарі землі -
господарі (кого? чого?) землі
по-материнськи зростила -
зростила (як?) по-материнськи
теж словосполучення
нас зростила (кого?)
нас - теж словосполучення
піднесла до сонця - піднесла
(до кого? до чого?) до сонця
піднесла на крилі -
піднесла (як?) на крилі
жар любові - жар (кого? чого?) любові
в серце заронила -
заронила (куди?) в серце
жар заронила - заронила (кого? що?) жар
Як бачимо, в кожному із цих словосполучень
є слово головне і слово залежне
Ось так і потрібно шукати словосполучення.
А тепер пропоную попрактикувати.
Наш “улюблений” суржик, щоб
його ніколи не використовувати.
Неправильно говорити
бувший у використанні - вживаний!
Халатне відношення - недбале ставлення.
Не в стані - не в силі (щось зробити)
По крайній мірі - принаймні.
Використовуйте правильно українські слова.
Гарного вам настрою і до
зустрічі на наступних заняттях.